race day your pulse pounds your head
throbs your adrenalin rushes the
starting gun goes off and so do you into
a wall of creeping runners that
accordion leg crush of runners waiting
to get out of their starting Corral's
intrigued scientists who wondered if the
movement could be modeled to find out
they filmed thousands of runners from
high level balconies as they left the
starting Corral's of several major
marathons scientists used an algorithm
to track the speed of runners as they
move to the starting line when directed
by race staffers runners shuffled
forward several meters before stopping
and starting up again the speed and
density changed and moved backward
through the pack of runners like a wave
the scientists discovered that the waves
move back at a constant rate which means
that they can estimate how long it takes
for the change in speed to travel all
the way through the crowd the faster
blocks were usually the same length as
the distance the race staffers moved
forward each time they set out from a
complete stop but unlike the waves that
traveled back through the racers no
waves traveled from side to side
despite imperfections in the crowds
movement this is one of the first
studies to look at the physics of human
movement not at the individual level but
at the level of the whole crowd similar
to previous studies in bacteria
scientists say this research could be
helpful for crowd management or creating
more accurate visual effects of crowds
and movies their model of how waves of
speed and density traveled they're
confined crowds could also lay the
foundation for understanding how crowds
respond to emergencies for now it could
help make your cue up to the starting
line a little bit smoother
[Music]